HIS BEST ASSET IS HOW PENALTY I
TODAY'S GAME
OTTAWA.: STILL LOBBYING,OOKING R
TKACHUK, DROPS IT BACK TO
ZAITSEV, IN, SHOOTS,  SAVES IN .
TKACHUK GETS HIS FIRST GOAL IN
15 GAMES
>> G GHROWS IT IN FRONT OF
CONNOR BROWN, ROLLED TOOKING FO
OUT TO THE SHORT SIDEMENT YOUHE
.
10 SECONDS TO GO IN THH
FORMENTON, STÜTZLE, TO CHABOT.
TERRIFIC-LOOK POWER PLAY.
TIERN
AND CHRIS TIERNEY, GETS THAT
BACK TO BRANNSTROM.
INSIDE  BY FORSBERG IN
TIGHT AS TROCHECK TRIED TO WALK
AROUND HIM PENALTIES.
>> Gord: NEVER DULL BETWEEN
THESE TWOBYNG AS THE
>> Jamie: GORD, I TALKED ABOUT
THE FAST START FROM THE SENATORS
IN THE FIRST
PAUL TO IKOV IS GOING TO TRY TO
OUTLET THE PASS THROUGH THE  RE
BACK AND CAROLINA ICES ITeANGEL.
IF FOR SVECHNIKOV.
MINUTES TO GO IN THE POWER PL W.
IN, SHOOTS, AND TAKEN B  BACK T
CENTER ICE.
ZAITSEV BACK AROUND.
SANFORD R R
STEPPING UP ON HIM BUT BATTLE
ALONG THE WALL, DOWN TO THE
FRONT OF THE HARD INTO UP BY  A.
ONE SHOT FOR CAROLINA ON THE
BACK DOWN FOR THE
ONE-TIT GOES JUST
ICE AND A SEEIN YOU HAD AHO